- Un invité remarqué, accueillir
de l'Université d'Ottawa :
l'ambassadeur chinois au Canada,
venu prononcer un discours sur
le campus. Depuis i,i,i,i,i,i,ie
prend de l'ampleur.
PABLO RODRIGUEZ
ministre du Pa- - - - - - - - -e
la presse, ça se négocie pas.
- C'est que l'accès au discours
de l'a
a été limité. Le caméraman
de Radio-Canada avait
d'abord été admis dans
la salle pour l'enregistrer.oure
du diplomate chinois s'est
opposé à la présence des
caméras. Résultat : l'Université
d'Ottawa a montramamamamamamama.
- Ça, il faut que ça s'en aille.
- Ne laissant pour seule option
aux journalistes présents
que d'enregistrer avec
leurs téléphones intellige
cette allocution importante...
(en anglais)
dénonçait la nouvelle stratégie
indopacifique du Canada.
Pendant le discours a a a a a t
les manifestants ouïghours,
à l'extérieur.
Cette entrave au travail
des journalistes faiENENENENENE.
des journalistes du Québec
- On est dans une pente
glissante, excessivement
glissante, et ça ouvuiuiuiuiuiur
l'expulsion des journalistes.
- Quand on invite un ambassadeur
d'un pays totalitaire, on lui
fait comprendre dè q q q q q q s
journalistes et des caméras dans
la salle, puis ça fait partie
des règles du jeu.
- Ce professeur de j r r r r r n
de sa propre université.
MARC-FRANÇOIS BERNIER, prof.
tit. Dép. comm. Univ. d'Ottawa
- En ce moment, le l l l l l l é
d'Ottawa qui a réussi... qui
a succombé ou qui a plié sous
la menace ou sous la pression
d'une vue ou d'uneetetetetetetee
de la liberté d'expression.
- Ce n'est pas la première
d'expression à l'Université
d'Ottawa. Une seseseseure
à temps partiel avait été
suspendue en 2020 pour
La classe politique dénonce
en bloc ce nouveodododode.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU
premier ministre du Canada
une erreur à bannir les caméras.
Les médias doiveiriririr accès.
YVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET
chef, Bloc québécois
se soit prêtée à ça me semble
indigne d'une inioioioion
qui est censée jouer un rôle
fort auprès d'une jeunesse.
Nouveau Parti démocratique
- La liberté des médias,
des journalistes, c'est
un droit fondamental.
- Les conservateurs s' s s s s r
les institutions d'enseignement.
PIERRE PAUL-HUS,é,é,é,é, PCC
Charlesbourg-Haute-St-Charles,Qc
- Ça démontre clairement
ce qui se passngngngngngngngngn,
d'interférence; que
l'ambassad C C C Chine demande à
l'université de fermer
les portes aux médias.
- Pa s s s s s s s s s s s s s e
sa conférence risquait d'être
lélélélée si les caméras avaient
été admises et rappelle que
les journalistes y ont eu accès,
sans mentionner la libertéde la.
Ici Louis Bloui